novembre 2018
le gouvernement ontarien fait des
compressions dans les services français
la grogne se transporte à l'assemblée
nationale du québec le drapeau franco
ontarien va flotter au dessus du
parlement de l'assemblée nationale une
motion adoptée à l'unanimité par les
parlementaires a imposé un tour de force
à l'équipe du protocole de l'assemblée à
pontarlier chargé du pavoisement des
drapeaux elle a dû faire vite car le
drapeau franco ontarien ne se trouvait
pas dans la collection j'ai appelé
directement fournisseurs pour savoir si
la vie est un exemple du drapeau dans
son stock donc heureusement il avait
avec lui pendant deux heures le drapeau
là avait été acheté à mener à
l'assemblée est ici sur le soul man 2
nootens parlement le fleurdelisé bas au
vent à l'année sur la tour principal
mais cinq autres tours a que des
drapeaux à l'accasion parfois en soutien
à une communauté ou une organisation
lors de la journée internationale de
lutte contre l'homophobie par exemple
mais surtout pour souligner la présence
d'une délégation étrangère j'ai le
plaisir de souligner la présence dans
les tribunes le l'ambassadeur de la
république du bénin en leur honneur le
28 février
des employés ont parcouru comme ils en
ont l'habitude un endroit bien méconnu
de l'assemblée nationale pour hisser le
drapeau du bénin le temps de la présence
de la délégation
et puis c'est pas rare qu'ils se mettent
à l'extérieur qu'il prend des photos
puis qui partage sur les réseaux sociaux
par la suite parce qu'ils sont fiers de
voir que leur drapeau létard bord et sur
l'hôtel du parlement
près de 500 drapeaux sont entreposés
l'assemblée nationale presque tous les
pays sont d'autres parlements qui
pavoise à l'extérieur lorsque des
dignitaires étrangers qui viennent
toutefois on est le seul parlement au
canada qu'il est et sur des tours
directement sur l'édifice et cette
tradition serait aussi vieille que
l'hôtel du parlement
construit il ya plus de 130 ans ses
propres au québec
c'est pour promouvoir la démocratie et
c'est pour pouvoir l'état de droit c'est
l'idée que le président veut faire des
associations avec des parlements
étrangers
et c'est dans ce cadre là qu'on fait
flotter
chaque drapeau est ainsi traité avec
soin le protocole a des règles à
respecter en matière de pavoisement les
drapeaux incarne plus que l'état lui
même mais bien une histoire est une
source de fierté